- Megan Walker a passé
une partie de sa vie à aider
les femmes victimes de violence.
Ce parc paisible au coeur
n, en Ontario, est
un endroit sacré pour elle.
C'est ici qu'on retrouve
le monument des femmes dédié
aux victimes de Poimes de Poime,
notamment.
"Un rappel de tout le travail
qui reste à faire",
explique-t-elle.
Megan Walker mène une bataille
pour que le terme féminicide
soit défini et inscrit
au Code criminel.
Le but : obtenir des données
sur les crimes motivés par
la haine contre les femmes,
sensibiliser la population
et influet influet influet infle
dont sont menés les procès
et les enquêtes criminelles.
"Cela mènerait les policiers
à investiguer les crimes contre
les femmes sous l'angle d'un
acte haineux", explique-telle.
Megan Walker siège
à la Commission des services
policiers de Londoerra
bientôt une lettre au ministre
fédéral de la Justice.
DAVID LAMETTI ministre fédéral
Justice, procureur gén., Canada
- Je suis prêt à écouter
des sugg
s'il y a des lacunes,
s'il faut combler des lacunes.
- Le gouvernement Trudeau
se montre ouvert
et évalue les possibilités.
- Il y a tout le temps
des options, c'est-à-dire
les options à la détermination
de la peine.
- L'idée fait du chemin,
y compris au Québec.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
premier ministre du Québec
- Je suis ouvert à ça, là.
Effectiv
des féminicides, puis on le sait
depuis longtemps ici au Québec
avec ce qui est arrivé
à Polytechnique.
- La pandémie et les
confinements ont ramené
à l'avant-plan la violence
contre les femmes.
Les chiffres sont éloquents.
Le nombre de femmes et de filles
tuées au Canada est passé
de 137, en 2019, à 173, en 2021.
"Oui, définir le féminicide,
mais la stratégie doit êtr
encore plus large", croient
le Bloc québécois et le NPD.
RHÉAL FORTIN, député, BQ
Rivière-du-Nord
- Il faut s'y attaquer,
il faut trouver une façon.
Alors, assoyons-nous à la table,
réfléchissons à ça comment
on lutte efficacement.
PETER JULIAN, député, NPD
New WestminsterBurnaby, C.-B.
- C'est triste de dire :
au Canada, aujourd'hui, on estvs
ressources nécessaires pour que
les femmes victimes de violence
ont une place pour se loger.
- "Il est temps de passer à
l'action", croit Megan Walker.
"Il faut arrêter de compteres d,
et passer de la parole
aux actes."
Ici Louada,
Ottawa